vamos a ver si podemos encontrar el
resultado de dividir dos tercios entre 5
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
bueno hay un par de formas en las que
podemos abordar esto la primera es que
podemos hacerlo de una manera conceptual
piensen en esto visualmente para hacer
esto déjenme representar dos tercios
esto que estoy dibujando aquí es un
entero
es un cuadrado que representa un entero
ahora voy a dividirlo en tres secciones
iguales se ve bien aquí tenemos tres
secciones iguales cada una es un tercio
y tenemos dos tercios en realidad
estamos representando esto que tenemos
aquí
y estos son mis dos tercios
ahora quiero dividir estos dos tercios
entre 5 bueno la manera de hacerlo es
dividiendo esto en cinco secciones
iguales pero si quiero hacer eso mejor
debería dividir todos los tercios en
cinco secciones iguales déjenme hacer
eso 1
[Música]
3 4 y 5 secciones iguales cuánto es una
de estas 5 secciones iguales de mis dos
tercios originales bueno esto que
tenemos aquí es una de las cinco
secciones iguales de los dos tercios
originales fíjense que puedo dibujar
otro de estos aquí y otro aquí otro acá
y otro acá y tengo cinco secciones
iguales que si las junto son dos tercios
pero cuánto representa una de esas
secciones sí podemos saber cuánto
representa esto del entero entonces
sabremos cuántos son dos tercios entre
cinco bueno cuando dividir los tercios
en cinco secciones igual es
esencialmente forme quince amos cómo
puedo saber eso bueno tengo uno dos tres
tercios y luego dividir entre uno
345 secciones así que cada uno de estos
cuadrados es un quinceavo tenemos 3 x 5
los puede encontrar si quieren y lo que
hemos encerrado en rojo es igual a 2 de
esos 15 años tenemos un quinceavo aquí y
215 ambos aquí así que esto es igual a
215 abós ahora otra forma de pensarlo y
de hecho de ahora en adelante esta será
la manera en que van a resolverlo cuando
dividimos entre un número es lo mismo
que multiplicar por el recíproco 5 es lo
mismo que cinco enteros o cinco sobre
uno y dividir dos tercios entre cinco es
lo mismo que dos tercios por el
recíproco de cinco o el recíproco de
cinco sobre uno y para obtener el
recíproco
simplemente intercambiamos el numerador
con el denominador así que es 1 sobre 5
otra manera de pensarlo es que esto es
un quinto de dos tercios que es igual a
una de estas secciones que tenemos acá
conceptualmente vemos que es igual a 215
abós pero también podemos decir
podría simplemente multiplicar esto
cuando multiplicamos fracciones
simplemente multiplicamos los
numeradores 2 por 1 es igual a 2 luego
multiplicamos los denominadores 3 por 5
es igual a 15 qué bueno que pudimos
dibujar esto para entender que dividir
es lo mismo que multiplicar por el
recíproco y cuando multiplicamos
fracciones es lo mismo que multiplicar
los numeradores para obtener el nuevo
numerador y luego multiplicar los
denominadores para obtener el nuevo
denominador terminamos